it's been america's longest running war
u.s troops were first deployed in
afghanistan 20 years ago
following the attacks on september the
11th
now it will be set as a date by which
the withdrawal will be concluded
the president has been consistent uh in
his view that there's not a military
solution to afghanistan that we have
been there for far too long that has
been his view for some time
this means president biden is pushing
back the deadline of the 1st of may
set by his predecessor donald trump last
year
it's a timeline which a number of
pentagon officials are believed to have
argued against
reaction in congress has been mixed the
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
describing the withdrawal as
a grave mistake have you shared in the
statement by the ranking member of the
house armed services committee
mike rogers who says i am concerned that
the president is so desperate
to get a deal done that he's willing to
capitulate
rather than insist u.s strategic
objectives are met
but there's also significant support for
the withdrawal
senate foreign relations committee
member chris murphy
issued the statement after 20 years it's
clear that our continued military
presence will not deliver political
stability to the country
and the afghan people must decide their
own future
in coordination with our allies and
partners
as vice president joe biden argued
strongly against the us military
presence in afghanistan
but was overruled then by barack obama
but now as president he'll have his way
a complete withdrawal of u.s forces with
no
conditions attached mike hanna al
jazeera washington